hi guys and welcome back to city
skylines
as you may be able to tell today's
episode will be about foliage also
adding some row houses of course and
messing around a little bit more with
flat neighborhoods though again I forgot
to add parking spaces that's something
which I'll get to in the future don't
worry about it I'll add them eventually
but for now people are just gonna have
to use the roads I suppose but something
which I really felt the need to talk
about in this video actually is the
time-lapse speed for those that don't
already know I speed up my videos by 12
times the speed which means that roughly
one hour of gameplay equals five minutes
of time Maps not even roughly really
correctly which I like at least and I'll
explain in a bit why but yeah it's very
fast for City skylines which I've got a
lot of comments about and it's something
which I try to fix for this episode and
decided to actually speak this one up
nine to ten times but it really doesn't
make too much of a difference and the
thing is I don't want to make the time
lapses much slower simply because this
is the format that I like to work with I
kind of play the game for what I make
rather than the gameplay as I make it so
just speeding up my gameplay like this
means that I get a lot more done in
shorter episodes which is what I
personally like so what I go for and if
I would have the speed of the time-lapse
one hour of gameplay would already turn
into fifteen minutes of video which
means that the average video we turn
into either 30 to 45 minutes of
time-lapse which I would have to like
talk over or put music over which I'm
not I wouldn't be a fan of or it's gonna
be the same length and I'm not going to
be able to get a lot done and truth be
told for me at least
my main focus is still on getting things
done and getting progress which is why
I'm still going to keep at least
speeding up my time lapses by at least
nine to twelve times but in the future
I'll actually keep track of that the
fact that I am time lapsing and make
sure that
I'm not moving around as much because
really this was recorded when I still
wasn't sure if I would actually put this
on youtube so I just kind of sat on my
computer and bulk record it for some
time just enjoying the game but yeah I
did move around a lot and that's and I
think that's the main issue so I'll
definitely hold the camera still and I
know for a fact that this is going to
make the time matches better and you'll
see why in a minute
basically in any case I wanted to do the
foliage in this episode because I didn't
really focus on it yet at this point and
I think it's actually one of the main
things that can either make or break
your city especially when it comes to
this city over here I really wanted to
get dense foliage and wherever I could I
wanted to get some ornamental trees
around the size of the roads
basically to juxtapose the very concrete
and unnatural look of the city itself
which has so many straight lines so much
asphalt and concrete and I switch my
loot there and Wow
and I really wanted to get more green in
there just to at least have more
different colors and make sure that not
everything looked so cold and dead and
unnatural which is why especially around
the roadsides over here I wanted to put
a lot of work into actually adding crown
shrubbery and other types of foliage
around the roadside which is something
that I do not expand upon in the future
because at the point of recording this I
still didn't have too many grants
rubbery assets and I think is really
important to at least be up-to-date to
know the assets so I actually am right
now as I speak I have downloaded just
about every foliage in the workshop so
I'll definitely come back to ground
shrubbery and foliage as a whole
later on we'll actually have more things
to work with but this is just sort of
laying down the bare bones and at least
making sure that this area looked
finished in terms of foliage but yeah
this is basically the part where I
actually did hold the camera still for a
number of times which looks so much
better I'll have to admit and I'm so
sorry about
moving a lot in all of the other
recordings I just so happened to stand
still for a number of times over here
because I figured might look better in
the time-lapse but afterwards I already
forgot that but it really does work a
lot better especially as you can see as
I'm placing these bushes over here you
could clearly much more clearly see what
I'm doing not just that it's less
nauseating to look at so that's a bit of
feedback for me in the future I'll
definitely work on that but so far the
first episodes are going to be the worst
I suppose in terms of how the time
lapses look and after that it should be
more like what you're seeing right now I
suppose just with the different lutes
because I can never make up my mind and
the core damn look that I try to use I
also keep like watching these YouTube
videos with people and of people and
seeing these lutes that I feel like I
don't have and are beautiful and I
should use but then when I find out what
you loot they use it doesn't even seem
to look the same for me I don't know if
this is just a mental thing or if my
game is just that [ __ ] up but I think
it's a mental thing anyway
but yeah I'll switch up my loot
eventually and hopefully as I switch to
the newest lutes
I'll keep it that way because so far the
look of the city has changed
dramatically because of the loot our
loot makes a lot a very large difference
in how your city looks really and I
think the current one that I'm using in
this video is just a little bit and not
just a little bit too dark it's actually
it's very brown orange yellowish it's
it's too yellow for me in general and a
little the contrast is pretty damn low
which I would also like to improve a
little bit and it's not really all that
bright I would like a little bit of a
brighter one I know the case I'm really
like Weisinger this area over here I
think it would be my second sort of
experimental flat neighborhood and I'm
actually much more happy with this one
than the first one it's a little bit
more Dutch especially with enlarged rows
of flats though I'm not too sure in the
flats near the river there
the only issue really is that I forgot
about the parking spaces again which is
something that I'll get to in the future
but for now we'll just have to do with
these paths I'll just replace the parts
with parking spaces in the future but
it's not too big of a deal but I just
feel stupid forgetting that the entire
time though I do have to add it was
surprisingly easy to replace all the
parts that I had alongside my flats into
parking lot spaces to make things a lot
more realistic and surprisingly that
there's like parking lots spaces that
you can just apply as text use as ground
text is that you can pretty much it but
anywhere you're very free to place them
anywhere and they don't really work as
parks or buildings that they snap to
Road and automatically make a connection
I was actually very surprised to find
out that cars can actually use them and
just drive over the textures because
they look like parking lots which I find
very interesting to look at now here's
where I start building a university but
I'm gonna have to add this is more of a
placeholder University and look I am not
quite too happy with it
I suppose I'll let it play for a little
bit but I'll actually just skip through
the major section of the university
since it's quite boring I think it's
very uninspired I just kind of wanted to
place this here just to have a
university sort of campus here because
anything would have been better than the
mass of random buildings that I had over
here before because I just figured I
would put a couple of buildings that I
needed in my city over here but this
campus is very simple and uninspired not
to mention it doesn't even have any
dorms which is weird
how can a university not have dorms so
this is something that I'll get to get
back to and try to improve probably just
completely remove and redo in the future
and this is currently more of a
placeholder anyway over here this is I
mean which I actually did want to show
off is going to be a new section of the
city and this is going to require a bit
of explaining before this is actually
going to be clear how this is probably
not even going to be clear after all my
explaining these I suck at it
but I'll try to do it anyway basically
at some places in the Netherlands and by
that I mean - at least - that I know of
there are very large roundabouts on
major intersection points and what
you'll find is that in the middle of
these roundabouts they actually have
pikes people were touch by knowing I'm
talking about and but if you don't then
it's gonna be hard to find any sort of
actually no nevermind I think Washington
has this as well I'm pretty sure
Washington has a ton of roundabouts and
a couple and I have parks in middle as
well and basically what I wanted to have
here was to make a large roundabouts
pretty much because I needed I needed to
do something at this major intersection
over here and a small roundabout maybe
wouldn't be able to take the eventual
traffic and I'm not sure if I wanted to
take the risk so I decided to place a
large roundabout over here anyway and
see if I could turn it into a pike and
then on both sides where you can
currently see like a little space of
about eight tiles between those roads I
want to have sort of elongation of that
same Park extending in that straight
line on both sides which is very much
inspired by a park with a large runabout
indoor right if you touch and you happen
to know about it this is inspired by it
and what's funny about this is actually
that it's more of a modern sort of I
mean it's more of an old actually Dutch
wrote layouts which so far I've actually
only seen in all the Dutch parts of
cities but it actually fits pretty well
I think with the very modern city
layouts especially since the roads are
also very straight and you've got that
large circle in the middle which you can
work around so I decided to place this
over here anyway and I think it works or
writes in the more modern neighborhood
although I suppose you be the judge
yeah this is what I wanted to mess with
over here officer actually got these
roads hooked up because that was a very
major issue for a long time I think this
time actually got it right there's like
the this was like the final sort of
solution here now something I wanted to
talk about is the suggestions that I've
got from people as well as some of the
ideas that I have myself that I'll take
you on the future not to spoil you and
anything that's happening in the future
but just to tell you
what I am thinking of so you don't have
to worry about its I suppose because
there's still a number of things which
I'm not going to tackle too soon but I
think that I'm definitely thinking of so
you don't really have to worry about
suggesting them to me everything that
I'm forgetting them there's stuff that
I'll get to in the near future for in
through a friend um for instance
elementary schools is something that I
want to get too many of them around the
cities because you'll find that a lot in
the Netherlands actually I also want to
have many playgrounds something which I
definitely like in at the moment to
shopping malls or small shopping streets
just about in every block of
neighborhoods is something that I won't
have in the future as well something
which you very commonly see in the
Netherlands I don't know about more
bodies of water since it's quite hard to
actually fit them in especially since
the map has some very smooth hails it's
something that I'm going to try in the
future industrial areas is something
which I'll have but at the later stage
things I'm gonna have them close to the
river and the highway which is where
I'll also add extra other things like
maybe an indoor ski resorts some larger
very large like shops like I don't know
which sort of stuff IKEA things like
that and maybe an amusement park
definitely expect especially with my
past experience I should have an
amusement park around here somewhere
anyway those are just a couple of
examples that I could think of that said
I like getting suggestions or feedback
whether it's positive or negative it
always helps and yeah that was really
about it all I wanted to say still had a
couple of flying camera shots since I
figured I could have them in here just
to kind of show what the city looks like
at the moment though it's not two grades
it doesn't show it all too much I'll get
the more sort of show off shots where
you can see the full layouts of the city
and as it sort of grows and the future
episodes I think episode four or five is
where I'll get to that also in the next
episode I'm gonna get to cauliflower
neighborhoods for those who don't know
who it is who that who those are go
the flower neighborhoods is sort of like
a I think they're a tongue-in-cheek name
but I I'm pretty sure they're actually
the real name for it are a type of road
layouts which is very twisted and has
sort of squiggly roads sprawled
alongside am center ring road I'm not
something which I'll get to in the next
episode so yeah thanks for watching and
I'll see you later